[Music]
now to a firsthand account of the legacy
of congressman john lewis who fought for
freedom
justice and what he liked to call good
trouble i like the sound of that
in 1965 is 25 years old when john lewis
helped lead a march from selma to
montgomery alabama
marked a turning point in the civil
rights movement cbs news reporter bill
plant was there to bear witness to that
he was just 27 years old five decades
later bill plant returned to the edmund
pettus bridge in selma
to mark the 50th anniversary of bloody
sunday planned who has since retired
from us at cbs
looks back at his reporter's notebook to
remember
john lewis as a young reporter who grew
up in chicago
i was a total cultural outsider to
both white people and black people in
selma alabama
but what i saw there opened my eyes
i was shocked by the raw hatred that i
saw as the black people there
tried to register to vote every day and
got beaten back by the local sheriff
and then when the voting rights marchers
went one night to a small town nearby
local people joined the state troopers
in beating the protesters and reporters
jimmy lee jackson was shot by a trooper
when he later died
it was during his funeral that john
lewis and others came up with the idea
of marching to the state capitol in
montgomery from selma
as a protest we'll march into our state
capitol to dramatize to our nation and
to the world
our determination to win first-class
citizenship
that march exploded into
state-sanctioned violence it will be
detrimental to your safety to continue
this march
for the troopers charged lewis was
beaten
trampled and gassed i thought i was
going to die
i thought i saw death but what amazed me
was that despite the anger
the protests remained nonviolent that
was hard for a lot of people to
understand the date we can march
by this very same spot without being
stopped and
without being harassed up to this point
but it was a goal from which dr king
and john lewis never wavered even though
as john lewis said at the time
it's hard to love the person who's
hurting me
what happened that day in selma
registered very sharply
in the conscience of the nation because
they saw it on tv
what was sought by this march from
settlement to montgomery
has been achieved a couple of weeks
later when the protesters were
successful
in reaching montgomery dr king predicted
that
segregation was on its deathbed john
lewis continued
to reach what he called the beloved
community
for many years he brought other members
of congress
down to what he called the sacred sites
of the civil rights movement
i think it's important for those that
was not even born not even a dream
to know what happened know the price
that was paid
the only thing i did i gave a little
blood that day we know now of course
that all that has happened
since selma hasn't ended racism
it still exists voting rights are still
not always guaranteed
but john lewis continued all his life to
make clear that
the struggle for equality continues
and even though he was a man of deep
faith he didn't preach religious values
he lived them he lived them humbly over
a lifetime of good example
to the rest of us
he always said that what he did was
getting in the way
making trouble but good trouble gail
yeah yeah yeah i look at those words
very differently now good trouble but
bill plant
what great memories for you and i love
when john lewis said all i lost was a
little blood that day
all i gave was a little blood that day
he gave so much more than that
well gail he was the real deal he is the
only
person in public life whom i covered
over 52 years at cbs
who always practiced what he preached
and you can't say that about anybody
else i can't
no no i'm with you on that you know they
they said about him that
he fought his whole life to show that
black lives matter that he never
judged you he just wanted you to be
responsible and he he never
ever missed an opportunity to educate
did you feel that was true too
based on your dealings with him oh
absolutely yes he
always was willing to explain why he was
doing what he was doing
and he was always willing to forgive he
forgave
george wallace the segregationist
governor of alabama
in the 60s who
who said on the steps of the capital
segregation now segregation forever
and john lewis forgave him among others
so he did practice no planets really
yes he did right up until the very end
it's good to see you bill plant at 27
and here we are in 2020. you look good
thank you so much for joining us
thank you reporter's notebook